[Music]
now throughout this
entire pandemic we've been following the
science but what about other experts
philosophers for example could tell us
whether lockdown is really the moral way
forward
and how to balance the costs to
livelihoods and lives
as we turn towards the next phase of the
pandemic these questions
should be coming to the fore and thought
about by more people than just
epidemiologists so today i'm joined by
two colleagues from the university of
oxford
professor julian savilescu is director
and professor dominique wilkinson is the
medical director
at the uhiro center for practical ethics
julian to start
despite his hesitancy to reopen the
prime minister has in the past
said that the measures will be
irreversible is he right to say that
well it definitely can't be irreversible
we could get a highly virulent strain
that that kills more people than earlier
strain so
it is possible that we would have to
lock down again but
but i think what the biggest problem in
this pandemic so far is that
the the metrics have been all wrong
we've been just looking at deaths and
and the death of a hundred year old
counts the same as the death of a 10
year old
and i personally hope i die at 100 and
not at 57
because it's much worse to die at 57. so
i think we need to start to
to to take a more mature approach to how
we measure
the impact of of any surge or any um
any flare-up and and we have to
to to not have this almost maniacal
obsession with covert deaths as the only
measure
you know i've seen estimates that
roughly as many people
will die as the result of lockdown
measures from non-covered related
causes as we'll die from covert related
causes so i think we need to start
thinking in a more balanced way
uh about the severity of of these
pandemics
um the nhs is one of the most
underfunded health systems in the world
or in the in the
western world and you know it regularly
run
runs up against the limit in a
non-covert related year so i think we
need more money injected into healthcare
rather than restricting people to their
homes
living in terror of going outside and
wearing masks continuously
and i think we need to think more
selectively about how
we we protect the vulnerable
while also allowing those who are not at
risk
uh and and people under the age of 30
really you know are not at a substantial
risk from covert and yet they've borne
the brunt of
of all of these restrictions and will
continue to so i think another measure
that we should be taking is more select
selective restriction of of
movement and freedoms uh to those who it
will benefit
rather than uh you know punishing
the the younger generations have already
paid too high a price for this
well dominic what do you think of
julian's claim that the death of a
hundred-year-old is much less sad than
the death of a
57 year old that seems to be suggesting
that lives have different values and
there's something that
some lockdown skeptics in the uk have
got into trouble for saying
well i think obviously life has value to
everybody who who who wishes to to stay
alive but we all of us have reason
uh if we if we're living well to want to
lie
to live for longer so i think
generally when we're thinking about
public health interventions we should
think
not solely about saving lives but also
about how long we might save lives for
and also how well people will live and
of course we're used to thinking about
that when we're thinking about quality
adjusted life years and
and working out which drugs will we fund
in our in our health system which
interventions we do need to think in a
sensible
uh and similar way about uh
the costs and benefits of interventions
uh in a pandemic but you kind of scared
of the question there do you think that
we should be valuing younger lives more
than older lives
well so i i think when we're thinking
about the the costs of the pandemic
at the costs to young people can be
great because they'll be born for a very
long period of time
somebody who might survive for a short
period of time
it's it's much less bad for them to die
than somebody who might die
for example a young person or a young
pregnant woman
uh who might have had many years of life
so all
deaths are not equal and again that's a
problem with
thinking purely in terms of numbers of
deaths so the
the british philosopher uh and
bioethicist john harris once proposed a
fair innings
of three score and ten um and and this
i think he's moved away from this view
now that he's over 70.
uh but this was also picked up by an
american philosopher dan callahan in a
book called setting limits that
you know we should set a reasonable
lifespan for people uh
and after that point we we shouldn't be
investing
large amounts of resources he was
talking about individuals in prolonging
their lives
this is not my view um but it was
callaghan's view
uh and and we've we've basically stopped
the world and the economy
uh in many cases to to to save the lives
of people who are
you know way beyond the sorts of limits
that harrison callahan were talking
about
so yeah i think if you look at
at the average numbers of years life
lost
from covid it's 10 years or more so it's
not simply the case as it's sometimes
claimed
that those who've died from covid have
have all been those who
who would otherwise have died within the
next winter from flu for example so i
think
it's important to recognize that that
covet has come at the cost of both lives
and life years and quality of life
so but those are all the things that we
should be
focusing on how do you get all of those
metrics together because
you know philosophers in the past have
tried to come up with um
algorithms or equations that kind of add
different parts together and end up with
sort of
pseudo i guess pseudoscientific uh
result of
morality but how do you measure all of
that do you add up tally up the amount
of years lost
depending on average life expectancy and
then just hope the best
from there yeah i mean there are many
different metrics for example there's
excess mortality that that you could
look at how how much worse are we doing
overall
compared to to previous years uh and i
think this is a very
very important question um and obviously
the government has settled on a very
simple metric of deaths because people
understand that it's a number
you know they can all grasp but it's
extremely crude
and and and that's only covert deaths so
i think we need to start to think
about how we can convey and measure the
severity
in in a more meaningful way as we go
forwards now
you know we probably did as well as we
can we could have done you know
everyone was operating you know in huge
pressures with inadequate information
and you know i i think it's probably
right to take death as your your metric
but come the next pandemic i think we
need to think you know
in a in a more nuanced way about how
we're measuring the
impacts of these kinds of things
well julian before we even get to the
next pandemic if you were
advising the government from you know
the sort of ethical perspective
of when to reintroduce restrictions if
we have to later this year you know
if you don't think death is a good
measure understandably for emergency
reasons it might be
would you be advising the government be
looking at
well i'd be advising them if if
the pressure on the health system was
such that
people under the age of 70 or 75 who
needed
life-saving uh interventions were not
getting them
so that would be my my metric that's a
simple one
um but i wonder what dominic would say
because he's at the cold face of working
in the hospital
yeah so so i think here we agree uh
actually the although there's lots of
questions about
how many deaths should we accept if we
want to to return to normal life i think
that's a mistake i think
the crucial thing is is uh can our
health system cope that's
in fact what's triggered many of the
restrictions in liberty that our health
system was in danger of buckling
with huge flow on consequences for
um people both with covert and with
other non-coveted illnesses people
who wouldn't be able to get into
hospital with their heart attack or
stroke or
wouldn't be able to get treatment for
their cancer so i think that is
the the relevant trigger point and the
reason potentially for unlocking now
is because in the short term it looks
like that isn't a pressing
danger and finally julian dominic i
wanted to get your opinion on this
question which is that do you think the
pandemic has made society
trend towards more towards the
collective in the near future as well so
whether it's the next global health uh
threat or something else
we're now more likely to be collective
in our morality
we're now likely to be caring more about
other people
in in our ethical concerns than just
than what we were before
well i mean i i think in in these sorts
of debates it's very easy to
to extrapolate from you and your friends
to how everyone thinks so
maybe we are thinking more collectively
in this group
but i'm i i know talking to taxi drivers
and people
out there there are many people who have
been really hurt by
the lockdowns and the policies who are
very disaffected so
i don't think i could generalize to how
people will think i think many people
will be skeptical
about the information that they've been
provided with about the level of
of protection and care that's been
exercised about the competence of
government
uh i think you know it may be that many
people are disaffected
um so i i think it's it's very difficult
to make generalizations
like that but dominic you probably see
more ordinary people than me
yeah i i don't know it it i think
we're not going to know for some time
what what the the lasting changes in
society and societal attitudes
are going to be from this pandemic but i
think one vector that's very significant
is global awareness uh
of of the vulnerability and the
fragility of our
uh of our communities of our health
uh i think many people in the general
public have been surprised by how
suddenly and dramatically
their lives could change and of course
that highlights the the the great
significance of some potential threats
and they include
further viruses but they also include
things like antibiotic resistance which
and uh is not only remains a kind of
potential
enormous threat around the corner but
actually has been exacerbated by some of
the
antibiotic use during the pandemic so so
i think
that sensitivity of which
and awareness of how our individual
well-being is connected to the
well-being of not only those within our
community
but also those around the world i think
that
is a potentially lasting change i think
that
that one i mean one important lesson i
hope
is that i mean some very
esteemed peoples like for example martin
reese the the
former president of the royal society
and astronomer royal
and others have have estimated there's a
50 chance we won't make it through this
century
uh and one of the causes of that will be
biological
as a species and one of the causes of
that will be biological weapons
um or could be biological weapons and
and this and and
sars cov2 is is actually
in the big scheme of things a very mild
infection
it's nothing like smallpox the mortality
is somewhere between 0.03
to 0.3 percent uh and it's completely
ripped apart the world
it kills people 90 of them over the age
of 65.
it's nothing like smallpox it's not as
bad as tb
so this is just a trial run for
what could happen and we haven't done
very well uh and the big picture for me
is as dominic says the fragility but
you better believe that this is not as
bad as it can get
and you know in in in within 10 years
tens of thousands of people will be able
to make something like stars cov2 where
even smallpox in a backyard laboratory
uh and release it uh you know as as a
as a malevolent act so you know we
we are really you know on the brink even
though we don't and this has been really
a wake-up call to just
how fragile our existence is um so we
really need to start thinking about
how to prepare for something much worse
than this
well on that cheerful note dominic and
julian thanks very much
remember we have a special subscription
offer for viewers
if you subscribe to the magazine you can
get 12 weeks off the spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds plus we'll
give you a 20 pound amazon voucher
completely free
and if you enjoyed this episode of
spectator tv why not subscribe to our
youtube channel for free
so you never miss an episode just click
the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and the bell icon to make
sure thanks for watching and do join us
again next week
when football will have come home
[Applause]
[Music]
is